you've got to do your research man
what's going on
guys at fifa if you are watching can you
actually put the real stats on the main
united players i'm not
quite happy with my speed in the game
especially because i play on the wing
now my qp i can do the same with qpr
please elevate us to the right level i'm
too small
i don't know who's doing the stats to
headquarters if you want me to come down
there and talk to you properly face to
face i'll do that yeah i'm not going to
talk about my stats doing a bit
disappointed to be honest
it's a joke i need a more three or five
sentiment
can you explain that please do you want
someone a little bit quicker than
what i am in the game go on and explain
it though what speed are you in the game
uh
i tweeted last year about it i'm on 81
or 82 it's not enough i'm quick man
i was i was quick i was i was
you